Chris Pratt makes his first public  appearance and splitting from Anna Faris  what a morning the services in lieu of  the Teen Choice Award fresh was all  smiles at the Teen Choice Awards Sunday  noticeably not wearing his wedding ring  when he picked up a surfboard for choice  knife i movie actor I would not be here  with the ease and grace I have in my  heart without my Lord and Savior Jesus  Christ the guardians of the galaxy star  has kept a low profile since his split  from Anna Sunday was not only his first  time back in the spotlight since the  surprising separation but also marked  his first time back at the Teen Choice  Awards in 13 years he last attended the  event when his show Everwood was  nominated in 2004 we ready to plug away  any other you know this evening were all  very excited and grateful be working so  yeah  [Music]